uh let's cross though to Susie Crozier
flinton who's a member of the covid-19
bereaved families for justice group and
she joins me now very good to talk to
you today uh what are your thoughts
today on hearing this response from the
Privileges committee
I think it's overwhelmingly unsurprising
this is nothing that we didn't already
know
um I think the most shocking thing is is
the flagrant disregard that Johnson is
showing towards the Privileges committee
um the the sort of attack on on
Democracy that seems to be going on but
no I'm not surprised by anything that
the committee has found because I
already knew
um we saw the photographs we heard him
lying to Parliament we already
have the evidence in front of us for him
to try and deny it is absolutely risible
um and also you know particularly
shocking is a statement from
um the second report where there's
talking about not adhering to the rules
inside number 10 but making sure they
pretend they are when their our cameras
present
um I mean this is this is someone who is
supposed to hold the highest honor in
the land who is embarking upon
completely self-serving Behavior at the
expense of Our Lives essentially
I mean when we when we look at how Boris
Johnson handled covid he he was a man
who was very very ill himself he you
know he was in a perilous situation in
hospital so a lot of people will say
he knew what a lot of families you know
like yourselves were going through he
was there at the sharp end he he felt it
he was just doing what he thought was
right
well if that is the case he should have
demonstrated a lot more empathy if he
was so ill that he almost died as he
claims then surely he understood just
how severe this virus was and is and
just exactly what the risks were around
you know having indoor Gatherings and
being in close contact and sharing
breathing space and all that sort of
thing he should have understood from a
very deeply personal level just exactly
what a danger there was
um so I'm afraid I don't I don't hold
truck with any argument because he
almost died that informed his decision
because actually if he was as ill as he
says he was then he should have made
better decisions to keep people safe
knowing how dangerous
and how threatening the virus is
um and it sounds to me like more Johnson
obfuscation
do you holding truck with with the
thoughts as well that people may say
well you know they may have been doing
something wrong inside number 10 they
may have not been you know abiding by
the rules but overall the rules that
they implemented and the introduction of
the vaccines were effective some would
argue
um and and by you know that almost that
is the bigger thing that is the more
important thing what do you make of that
um I think the point is that you know by
March 2020 we'd already seen across the
world the effects of the virus we had
those Dreadful scenes from Spain from
the care homes in Spain
um you know as well as news coming out
of China and other countries so you know
the fact of the matter is that we didn't
do enough we didn't do it quickly enough
and any other arguments you know that
okay vaccine roll out yes that was
absolutely fantastic it's utterly
amazing and but actually there were
measures that we could have put in place
a lot earlier and a lot harder that we
just simply didn't do